editor's take raw mass and sculpt it
down to its essential kernel of truth
what a particularly sadistic butcher
might do to let's say a rump roast or a
ham hock an editor must do to film we
actors love our editors they protect us
they on occasion lie for us they
hypothetically might hold on a shot of
my watering eyes put a lump in the
audience's throat voguing that deep deep
emotion never telling a soul that my
award-winning emotional depth may have
possibly been just something stuck to my
contact irritating my eyeball but again
that's just you know a hypothetical
example I was using editors make so many
of us look way better than we ever have
the right to and here the nominees for
achievement in film editing Argo William
Goldenberg Life of Pi Tim Squires
Lincoln Michael Kahn silver linings
playbook Jay Cassidy and Crispin
Struthers zero dark thirty villain
Tichenor and William Goldenberg and the
Oscar goes to
William Goldenberg Argo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys thank you all so much
thank you members of the Academy for
honoring our go with this award I really
really appreciate it I want to thank my
great crew Bret Joe and Paula I want to
thank Warner Brothers and I want to
thank our great producers George Clooney
and grant Heslov and Chris Terrio for
writing an editor's dream for a
screenplay and Ben I share this with you
you're my brother I love you and thank
you for this
my wife Allison and my great children
Nathan are there and thank you so much
you made this all possible and thanks
everybody thank you good night
[Applause]